in this video I want to talk about the
nitrogenous bases which are the purines
and the pyrimidines so let's start off
with the purines the purines are named
for their parent compound purine which
is this structure here notice how I
numbered it here the the numbering for
this purine is in is numbered in this
way and notice none of these have
Prime's and that's actually the reason
that the ribose sugar or the deoxyribose
sugar in nucleotides Renuka size have
Prime's because they can't have the same
number as the nitrogenous base so the
nitrogenous bases have no Prime's the
sugars themselves have Prime's
so the purines I remember them as pure
as gold or pure as silver silver' has
the elemental symbol a G so the a and
the G represent adenine and guanine so I
remember that there are two of them
there are two purines and each one has
two rings that kind of helps you
remember
so they both look like this adenine
guanine looks like this they have a six
member membered ring next to a five
membered ring may have these four
nitrogen's so they both look the same so
far I'm going to go through and draw out
the differences and similarities so they
both have double bonds here here and
here they both have those double bonds
and they also have h is attached to this
nitrogen down here and this nitrogen
here is actually important specifically
it is on a box it in orange it is the
attachment site where the sugar is bound
to the nitrogenous base and a nucleoside
ur nucleotides so I'll get to that in
just a moment now adenine has an amino
group up here whereas guanine has a
carbonyl group there so since this
carbon has four bonds already it can't
form a double bond here so this nitrogen
has a hydrogen this one however there is
a double bond so this nitrogen does not
have a hydrogen attached to it in
addition guanine has an amino group here
okay so the differences are basically
what's going on here and here and here
right because adenine doesn't have
anything there
okay now this orange box is where the
nitrogenous base attaches to the pentose
sugar via a beta one prime n glycosidic
bond what is that
well the sugar itself the pentose sugar
will be beta at the anomeric carbon
which is actually where it which is the
1 prime carbon right that one prime
carbon is connected to this n hence this
n here so it's a beta 1 Prime and
glycosidic bond this is the nitrogen
that's that the sugar will be attaching
to so that's it for the purines now the
perimeters are named for their parent
compound parameter and it's numbered in
this fashion so the way I remember the
pyrimidine x' is either one of these two
ways cut the PI Cu T so I have seen
uracil thymine or pyramids right
pyramids have sharp edges if you look at
this little pyramid drawn here pyramids
have sharp edges and sharp edges cut so
Cu T so either way that whatever helps
you remember that's how I remember the
pyrimidine so the perimeters I'll have
one ring structure in these two
nitrogen's they all kind of look like
this
they all have a double bond here at the
right side they also have hydrogen's at
this nitrogen and that's actually their
attachment site for all of them ok in
addition they all have carbonyl group
here at the bottom left now the
difference is that cytosine has an amino
group up here whereas uracil and thymine
both have carbonyl groups now because of
that cytosine can have a double bond
here so that it's like this nitrogen
does not have HS but these two
nitrogen's do have a CH is attached
because they can't double bond so what's
the difference between uracil and
thymine basically thymine is just uracil
with a methyl group so that's
essentially the difference there
so between cytosine uracil and thymine
cytosine sort of separates itself by
having that amino group but between
uracil and thymine the only difference
between them is the presence of this
methyl group here so that
for the pyramids I hope that was helpful
overall in sort of going over the pre
oriented permitting that's the end of
the video one last thing I am a tutor so
if you live in Southern California feel
free to contact me via email at move
University at gmail.com there's more
details in the description below thanks
for watching